wir kommen nach berlin nach deutschland
wir haben einen preis bekommen nämlich
gestern wurde der german boxing award
verliehen und bild war nicht nur dabei
wir haben auch abgeräumt und einen der
begehrten box oscars bekommen
[Musik]
wer boxen sehen will der kug bild tv die
fight night überträgt die größten
boxkämpfe und dafür werden wir jetzt
hier mitten in berlin am tipi am
kanzleramt geehrt mit dem oscar der
boxwelt der herr kohl der german boxing
award wurde in zwölf kategorien vergeben
etwa 300 geladene gäste nahmen an der
veranstaltung teil der rote teppich
prall gefüllt mit promis und sämtlichen
größen der boxwelt mir ist vor allem
wichtig dass auch mal die boxer und
boxerinnen wirklich im mittelpunkt
stehen weil die sind es nicht so oft
gewöhnt die ganz große bühne und das ist
hier genau der richtige rahmen finde ich
es einfach aufregend hier zu sein so
viele leute zu sehen und ja es ist mal
was neues ich bin ganz gespannt auf die
laudationes hat ist glaube ich der
richtige bohrer die gehalten werden
für mich ich bin heute für mein
freundlich unterstützt unseren promoter
mehr am boxen immer imponiert das ist
sozusagen die ultimative zusammenfassung
aller werte ist auf die es ankommt mich
fasziniert einfach so diese
vielfältigkeit und die starken männer
sogar wladimir und vitali klitschko
seinen grußbotschaften per video für
sein lebenswerk wurde der frühere
universe manager peter hanraths
ausgezeichnet hanraths reiste extra aus
mallorca zu diesem mega event an auch
wir von bild tv haben eine box oscar
bekommen denn kein sender steht für
boxen sowie bild mit der fight night
bringt bild diese kampfsportart wieder
ins deutsche fernsehen dass wir uns
selber als mission gesetzt haben um
exciting graser denn das war die große
messe die über allem stand werden wir
versucht in den letzten eineinhalb
jahren wieder boxen sollen fähig zu
machen welche medien neigen passt
eigentlich am besten zum boxen dann lass
mich nachdenken ist man schnell bei bild
also bild und boxen das passt einfach
und genau dafür wurde bild zwischen den
größen der boxwelt mit den herr kuhl in
der kategorie tv und streaming
ausgezeichnet der frühere hertha manager
michael preetz hielt die laudatio
bild tv chefredakteur claus strunz nahm
den herr kuhl entgegen
so nehme ist er claus strunz wie stolz
bist du den preis in hand saal ist das
ding der box oscar wir freuen uns
wirklich weil box muss total am herzen
liegt und wir richtig gas geben wollen
das wird in zukunft noch so kommen naja
wir wollen versuchen die großen kämpfe
bei bild zu zeigen wir haben ja mit
tyson fury schon mal richtig vorgelegt
vor einigen wochen und monaten und
da kommt noch ganz ganz viel da würde
ich sagen die wir zuschauer seien sie
schon mal gespannt die nächste fight
night bei bild wird heiß
[Musik]